in today's video we focus on the key
game of the fourth round of the sham
gear just tournament Fabiano Caruana
versus magnus carlsen Caruana happened
to be the very last opponent Carlson
that lost the game to back in June 2013
before he was world champion at the doll
Memorial in Moscow and again Cara wanna
manage to set huge problems for his
opponents especially after Carlson
blundered upon in the early stages of
the game in this position from a Berlin
endgame White has a nice advantage black
should have played the move c6 after
which white is still better but material
remains equal however in the game
Carlson played rather quickly in fact
king c8 missing the tactic Knight takes
c7 if black takes the knight then the
move is 6 check more or less decides the
game white will take this d7 bishop and
have a rook on the seventh rank
therefore Carlsen needed to play roof d8
and after 95 White was a healthy pawn up
although Carlsen managed to find ways to
complicate the position Carolina
continues to play accurately and won
after time control we spoke to the
winner about the tough decision he had
to make on move 41 and we also spoke to
his coach before the time control I was
already calculating this it was actually
my intention quite a bit before move 40
but then I at the last moment I when I
had 20 seconds left I saw rook g4 which
is what he played but and I got very
nervous because I saw Bishop e3 Bishop
before and and I felt like maybe I could
also lose so I didn't want to take the
risk and not see freely it seemed like a
safe option but then okay after he
played rook e8 I realized that I I have
this option again and it makes sense to
just calculate it because I have quite a
lot of time King g3 was very safe and
probably also winning but the variation
he gave him the press conferences Bishop
c7 King c8 and we should be Ages is what
I was mainly looking at I I wasn't sure
I mean I didn't see a clear way to clear
away to make progress after that you
know he plays Bishop d7 Bishop e6 and
it's easy to to lose track of video and
screw it up so I decided that it's more
forcing and I'll take the risk that I
might miss something
I kept on playing and he is pretty good
at finding the most annoying moves even
in lost positions were you after that
any a moment worried well in general I'm
always a bit worried that I might bond
with something because it's a very
complicated position there was always
some you know checks on g1 but I didn't
see anything so I am I'm pretty sure
there wasn't anything and he didn't see
it either Jerry speaking it's of course
not
the first encounter for Deanna playing
Magnus it's also not the first time he
succeeded although it's clear that of
course each game against the Magnus it's
some kind of trial sometimes I cannot
say that we did some special
psychological preparation mostly it was
clear that it's to be concentrated to be
focused during the game and it was clear
that we wanted to have a fight today so
of course it's always depends you know
chess it's not always depends on your
own wheel it's also your opponent so but
somehow out of the opening we got a
position that we already had analyzed
previously and Fabiano had a clear idea
what he is doing so by all berlin
standards it was some pressure on blacks
position and this time an opposite to
the game against a ciggy Karekin for the
unemployed really accurately through all
the game so I still denies it in details
but it looked like very smooth game
actually so of course I trusted that he
was calculating quite some time of
course you know tiredness it's always
important factor in any game but somehow
okay there are young players so I was
quite confident that he calculated the
consequences